let's go
and now i did the old trick where she
made her her first move and then i i
wait
game was originally supposed to start at
uh at eight
sharp um
and now i waited for for her to to make
a move okay so
um
i waited to make make a move till to she
was gone evidently so i will read my let
my uh cr clock run a little bit to to
make it a bit more
more fair um i am after all
here to
teach the kids some some chess lessons
not to
not to hustle them if i if i can afford
not to
so i'll be going for uh
for a night or fair
against the youth
which
seems like a
questionable
strategy to to say the least but
there you go
um
the e6 uh yeah she's thinking a bit here
there are
usually have the choice between g4
bishop e2
and uh
and f3 okay so she just goes for a more
um
standard
screaming in
type of position
which i guess is reasonable
um
ah king h1 i'm not too sure about i
think you should go a4 there and
sort of force
um forest knight c6
yeah she's 24 400 okay a3
then i'm getting easy development bishop
b7 bishop f3 knight d7
and i'm i should be fine
next i'm thinking of moves like
look rook c8 and also bishop c5
knight b6 to c4 is also an option
g4
um
then i would go knight c5
so as long as she's not in time to do
that then
i'm
i have some positional advantage and
quindi 2 is really really inviting
knight b6 i don't see any reason not to
go for it
knight c4
guess i'm just gonna keep developing
rook ft8
perhaps intending d5 knight e4 at some
point
may work tactically
uh but in general it's it's hard for her
to find active ideas here
um
yeah
b3 clearly is the plan so i think it's
time for me to strike in the center
so we get a
sort of a turbocharged
charge french for me here
where um
i already have had knights in e4 and c4
and that
[Music]
clearly gives me a pretty
pretty serious head start
c3 i guess is the best chance but uh
yeah b3 i think i'll just go knight a5
i can take first as well maybe that's
even more precise
don't know what is more precise anyway
let's be a little bit more flexible and
go knight a5 freak b1 i can take on d4
or even knight b3
the point is after bishop d4 cd4
this one is attacked right at the end
[Music]
and that by the way is the first arrow
i've ever drawn
it's a milestone
okay knight b3
should be winning on time here
regardless but i'm
gonna try and uh
finish in style e3
opening up for uh
for uh for this bishop towards the king
uh and now
oh that was a bit too much
so my first error was good the second
and third not so much rook 82 is the
only chance here
uh but i think my opponent she's
probably clearly better at classical
than um
um
[Music]
than than blitz and uh in the end this
was fairly
comfortable for me